quand une balle sort du canon d'une
arme à feu, elle sort à 513 degrés
Fahrenheit y a-t-il un problème d'officier
pas encore
après ce week-end j'ai fini où est ma
lettre de démission nous parlerons de
vous à chaque fois et quand vous reviendrez je
je viens de sortir de prison pour crime je n'ai pas
fait 513. tu sais ce que c'est c'est un
code c'est mon pote mike dont je
te parlais j'ai besoin d'un mitrailleur au cas où
quelque chose va au sud tu sais
qu'on y va on ne fait pas  rien de mal mais
prenez l'argent et ensuite nous partons alors il a
obtenu la carte laissez-moi prendre la route secondaire
vers le mexique
semble facile
revenez en ligne droite ne vous arrêtez pas
pour rien appelez-moi dès que vous arrivez
dans les états
ce n'est pas  ce que vous pensez officier,
c'est un travail simple
et nous allons au coffre-fort, vous gagnez,
il s'agit de l'argent que
mon petit frère est sorti de prison, vous êtes
bon, je vais bien, je dois rentrer à la maison,
faire mes bagages et partir pour quelques jours  pourquoi
moi pourquoi pas tu les as regardés droit dans les
yeux tu lui as dit que tu étais en bas tu
veux  fais-moi tuer essaie de te faire
tuer au revoir papa je t'aime mon bébé es-
tu dans une sorte de problème je ne peux pas faire
ça maintenant
j'ai besoin de savoir que mon argent va
être sécurisé aujourd'hui tu as une idée de qui
aurait fait  une telle chose stupide qui
vole votre
banque nos gens nous attendent
vous n'allez nulle part je vous suggère de
faire ce que l'homme dit
il y a beaucoup de choses que je n'ai pas faites je vais
faire ce marché avec vous mais je dois vivre
je n'ai jamais tué personne non je dois les
remplir plus vite
tu me mets dans une position embarrassante et
ça me met très en colère ces gars
ils vont me tuer et ils vont tuer
toute ma famille
c'est vrai ce qu'ils disent
ce qui arrive te
tourne autour